then if you learn how to dance well
she'll think your boss
Lisa Loring the child star who played
the original Wednesday Adams on The
Addams Family from 1964 to 1966 has died
she was 64 years old Lisa's daughter
Vanessa foundberg confirmed the news
over the weekend explaining in a
statement to variety that her mom died
of a stroke on Saturday quote she went
peacefully with both her daughters
holding her hands close friend and TV
producer Lori Jacobson also confirmed
the actress's death on Facebook writing
that Lisa is embedded in the tapestry
that is pop culture and in our hearts
always as Wednesday Adams
[Music]
the playroom
it isn't nice to tattle thing but thank
you anyways Lisa began modeling at a
young age and was cast in an episode of
Dr Kildare before landing the role of
Wednesday when she was just six years
old oh hello Wednesday darling come and
see the new pet we have for you do you
like him he's very nice but I'd rather
have a spider
Lisa's portrayal of the iconic character
paved the way for Netflix's 2022 series
Wednesday starring Jenna Ortega why
should I bother telling you anything
you've already decided I'm lying when we
talk about you transforming into this
role I mean you play the cello you're
fencing in it what was training like so
I would do the 12 14 hour work day and
then I would have cello and fencing at
the end of my day Jenna even credited
Lisa for inspiring her now viral
Wednesday dance
[Music]
so I paid homage to at least alluring
the first Wednesday items I did a little
bit of her Shuffle that she does the
dance did you know that it would go
viral crazy viral no I even thought I
still can't believe because it was kind
of on some of it I some of the moves I
had planned some of it was improv that
was one of the scenes that I stay awake
at night thinking about because I
thought there was so much that I should
have done and could have done so the
fact that anybody has shown any bit of
appreciation or I've even tried it
themselves is kind of um it's not
fathomable to me after The Adams Family
went off the air Lisa appeared on The
Pruitts of Southampton in 1966 and in
her 20s she played Cricket Montgomery in
the soap opera As the World Turns Marco
are you sure that that's what they were
doing come on Cricket
course I'm sure Lisa was married four
times first to Farrell faumburg when she
was 15. the marriage ended after about a
year and she later married Doug
Stevenson Jerry Butler and Graham Rich
Lisa is survived by her two daughters
Vanessa whom she shared with Farrell and
Marianne whom she shared with Doug as
well as her grandchildren emiliana and
Charles
[Music]
thank you